so every year on my birthday it's the
worst day of the year because
everybody's going everyone [ __ ] with me
oh [ __ ] what's the worst prank you got
what i'm about to say involving my
brother
i was drinking the night before it's
almost my birthday what's up
i think this was when we were still
friendly but after this after this i
think what i'm about to explain was my
first initial thought of like oh this
kid doesn't give a [ __ ] about real life
it's all content for him so let's make
it about content at the time like he he
would do anything for on for online and
so when i
like i i don't know just we do and so
okay one day come on in the garage a
little hungover drinking the night
before and uh my brother's at my
apartment bright and early as 10 a.m i
got that like morning hangover i'm kind
of the delusional delirious i mean my
emotions it's my birthday
and he goes brother i got you this lambo
for all the success we've had this
lamborghini right here hands me keys to
a [ __ ] lamborghini white lamborghini
it's beautiful 450 thousand dollar car
we get in it
i mean jake are vibing and talking about
like how far we made it right we have
all these subscribers on on youtube this
fandom came from ohio
i go jake you know brother this is the
happiest moment of my life and i mean
that
nearly in [ __ ] tears because i got
you bro and i and i go and this isn't a
prank it's not a joke he goes nah bro
i'm like oh my mom's like you swear to
god he goes swear to god bro
like damn this [ __ ] really just
got me a lamb but we really [ __ ] made
it i i was about crying
i get out of the car we're all like wow
you know jake is such a good guy
and some [ __ ] guy comes up to me and
goes
yo can i get the keys in my car back
i'll go what what what car
you're like the lamborghini
i'm like what that
and everyone starts laughing at
me [ __ ]
everyone starts laughing at me because
it was a prank bro
that sounds like some deep [ __ ] you
gotta stop right now
like you're saying it
like
[Laughter]
it was a prank bro
so then what happened what did you say
then i was like
damn
i was embarrassed
i felt stupid i felt betrayed
and then we just started the beef heated
up and then next thing you know we're
making diss tracks he made a video out
of that one
yeah he he made a video his his diss
track was called so my group my fandom
was called the logang and by the way the
logang [ __ ] lives on i swear to god i
swear to god i'll be at the most random
events wwe online discord [ __ ]
[ __ ] no we live up there i know
they're out there
yes
i can hear it i hear a statistical
when you went to that flat earth
conference and it was all your boys from
logan
that's that's that's tough okay that
started out because you got to give them
love you know you gotta believe these
dogs beliefs are believed
yeah [ __ ] you i don't [ __ ] know about
i don't know the earth could be flat i
don't it might be i don't think it
[ __ ] is okay but go on the low gang
was riding with you yeah the low game
was already
he made a song called the the logang as
[ __ ] or some [ __ ] it's like the low
gang-ish
and it just [ __ ] peeved me my brother
was catching up to me little brother was
catching up to me on youtube you dogged
me in front of the whole internet i
can't believe this is real
it sounds dumb
no they don't sound
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
white privilege is a beautiful thing
you bring me with a lambo on my birthday
i'm gonna kill you
arbitrary it could be anything what else
could it be
anything like for example did you get
those on
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
is everybody else seeing this
[Laughter]
[Music]
no nothing that's it
so what concluded the beef what actually
yeah how did you squash it what did
happen
it's a good question bart
nice question bro no
no it wasn't
the advertisers can include the b oh i
actually i don't know i think i think
it's his little no you know
there wasn't a moment but enough things
happened shitty in each other's lives
and we will always have each other each
other's backs no matter what happened
then
and that happened enough times for us to
realize that our bond as brothers is the
most important thing in the world like
number one there's nothing there's
nothing i love more in this world than
jake
and and it's it's through these trials
and tribulations that i learned that
like empathy and love especially just it
wasn't like the way i was raised it
comes a little slower to me and i'm
learning and getting better at it but
like
um
uh
really cherishing the love of my sibling
in my adult years now i feel it
i really
and it means a lot to me and so now you
know we're [ __ ] best friends i think
he's great and uh do you regret the beef
you know what i don't
i don't i
i regret the
the riff that it caused in the family
yeah but i don't i don't regret the the
beef i i think it was a part of our
history i only i only have two regrets
in life which are what stupid um
japan